- [Instructor] What we
wanna do in this video
is get an understanding
of how we can approximate
the area under a curve.
And for the sake of an example,
we'll use the curve y is
equal to x squared plus one.
And let's think about the
area under this curve,
above the x-axis,
from x equals negative
one to x equals two.
So that would be
this area right over here.
And there's many ways
that I could tackle this,
but what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna break up this interval
into three equal sections
that are really the bases of rectangles.
And then we're gonna think
about the different ways
to define the heights of those rectangles.
So once again,
I'm going to approximate
using three rectangles
of equal
width.
And then we'll think
about the different ways
that we can define the
heights of the rectangles.
So let's first define the heights
of each rectangle by
the value of the function at the midpoint.
So we see that right over here.
So let's just make sure
that it actually makes sense to us.
So if we look at our first
rectangle right over here,
actually let's just first appreciate,
we have split up this x,
we have split up the interval
from x equals negative one
to x equals two into three equal sections,
and then each of them have a width of one.
If we wanted a better approximation
we could do more sections
or more rectangles,
but let's just see how
we would compute this.
Well the width of each of these is one,
the height is based on
the value of the function
at the midpoint.
The midpoint here is negative 1/2,
the midpoint here is 1/2,
the midpoint here is 3/2.
And so this height is going
to be negative 1/2 squared
plus one.
So negative 1/2 squared is 1/4 plus one,
so that's 5/4.
So the height here is 5/4.
So you take 5/4 times one.
This area is 5/4, let me write that down.
So if we're doing the midpoint
to define the height of each rectangle,
this first one has
an area of 5/4.
Do it in a color you
can see, five over four.
The second one, same idea,
1/2 squared plus one is 5/4
times a width of one.
So 5/4 there.
So let me add that.
Plus 5/4.
And then this third rectangle,
what's its height?
Well we're gonna take the
height at the midpoint,
so 3/2 squared is
9/4 plus one,
which is the same thing as 13/4.
So it has a height of 13/4,
and then a width of one, so times one,
which would just give us 13/4.
So plus 13/4,
which would give us 23 over four
which is the same thing as 5 3/4.
And so this is often known
as a midpoint approximation
where we're using the
midpoint of each interval
to define the height of our rectangle.
But this isn't the only way to do it.
We could look at the left endpoint
or the right endpoint,
and we do that in other videos.
And if we wanna do it just for kicks here,
let's just do that really fast.
So if we wanna look at the left endpoints
of our interval,
well here our
left endpoint is negative one,
negative one squared plus one is two,
two times one
gives us two.
And then here the left
part of this interval
is x equals zero,
zero squared plus one is one,
one times one is one.
And now here our left endpoint is one,
one squared plus one
is equal to two, times one,
our base, is equal to two.
So here we have a situation
where we take our left endpoints,
where it is equal to two plus one
plus two or five.
Well we can also look
at the right endpoints
of our intervals.
So this first rectangle here,
clearly under approximating the area
over this first interval.
Its right endpoint is zero,
zero squared plus one is one,
so a height of one, width
of one, has an area of one.
Second rectangle here,
it has a height of, look
at our right endpoint,
one squared plus one is two,
times our width of one, well
that's just gonna give us two.
And then here our right endpoint is two,
squared plus one is five,
times our width of one,
gives us five.
So in this case we get,
when we look at our right
endpoints of our intervals,
we get one
plus two plus five
is equal to eight.
And eyeballing this,
it looks like we're
definitely over counting
more than under counting,
and so this looks like
an over approximation.
So the whole idea here's
just to appreciate
how we can compute these approximations
using rectangles.
And as you can imagine,
if we added more rectangles
that had skinnier
and skinnier bases but
still covered the interval
from x equals negative
one to x equals two,
we would get better and
better approximations
of the true area.